and now we come to the writers Awards
you will notice that I treat them with
great respect even though I write all my
own material now actually I bow toward
their guild building two years ago I
made the mistake of doing a joke about
writers now my next appearance the
teleprompter jammed and my idiot cards
vapor locked so to present the awards
here at two stars any writer is happy to
provide with words while this year's
nominees for best actor Rod Steiger and
his talented wife Claire Bloom
rod and Maharishi state are you ready I
am as ready as I'll ever be here
Oh your mind seems to be on something
else I can't imagine what that could be
never mind in the Writing Awards there
are two categories what are they they
are first the best screenplay based on
material from another medium the
nominees are Don Pierce and Frank are
Pierson for Cool Hand Luke
called a Willingham and buck Henry for
the Graduate Richard dropped four in
cold blood Sterling's elephant fur in
the heat of the night Joseph strict and
Fred Haines for Ulysses Claire would you
open the envelope
the winner is sterling silicon spittin
image of the night
I I really have no speech the Writers
Guild doesn't permit us to do any
speculative writing I'm deeply grateful
and very touched
Thank You rod Norman Waller Sydney
everyone thank you for the best story
and screenplay written directly for the
screen the nominations are Bonnie and
Clyde story and screenplay by David
Newman and Robert Benton divorce
american-style story by Robert Kaufman
screenplay by Norman Lear guess who's
coming to dinner
story and screenplay by William Rose
Legare a fini story and screenplay by
Jean simpang two for the road story and
screenplay by Frederick Raphael your
turn the winner is
William Rose for guess who's coming to
dinner
Award for William Rose Stanley Kramer
mr. Oz has been many times honored I
think if he were able to be here tonight
he would say this is most certainly his
greatest thank you